hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all requested it's the time
breaker game uh from the mini tournament
between maxine vashilagraw wesley so and
levon arunyan after the uh the final
round of the super bit chess classic
event so now the three of them are gonna
play a tiebreaker and whoever wins will
win the tournament as they finish the
tournament with the same amount of
points uh so by now you probably know
who won but just in case you don't we
are going to show the game and then we
are going to uh to discuss this as it is
quite quite an achievement so it's envel
with the white pieces against wesley so
with black and mbl opens with c4 he goes
for the english opening knight to f6 we
have knight to c3 e5 uh knight to f3 and
knight to c6 this is the very very
popular the four knights variation of
the english uh g3 uh preparing to
fianchetto the light square bishop uh d5
now striking in the center c captures
knight captures and now bishop to g2 so
we want to control the d5 square and
also the bishop will be beautiful on
this diagonal bishop to c5 uh the black
bishop will also be very very strong
here uh castles by mvl and here wesley
castles as well we have d3 and now pawn
to h6 not allowing any bishop to g5
moves with bishop to d2 now uh and uh
knight back to f6 so there's a lot of
pressure on this d5 square uh uh wesley
wants the uh to remove that and just
keep the pieces on the board we have
rook to c1 and wesley not worried about
the bishop being undefended on c5 he
just continues development rook to e8 as
you really don't have any any good
discoveries here now interestingly the
position has been reached before quite a
few times so for example levon arnhem
headed against anishigiri uh where
knight to h4 was played that game ended
in a draw but here we have a3 uh and now
uh again the position has been reached
one valley versus gwyn in 2019 where
bishop the f8 was played vanveli was
able to win that game but here
we have a5 and it is now as of move 11
that we have a completely new game so
instead of moving the bishop just
preventing b4 uh we have knights the a
for now attacking the bishop bishop back
to d6 and now mvl uh gets his knight all
the way to c5 and this is now a very
very annoying night um you want to get
rid of it as soon as possible and that's
exactly what wesley does uh by giving up
the bishop with bishop catrus and c5 you
don't play this because it just looks
very very
uh dangerous and it's a rapid game you
you can't really calculate what happens
uh so after knight to c5 bishop captures
on c5 and now we have rook calculus on
c5 and pawn to e4 this is what wesley
came up with uh it makes sense the pawn
on e2 will remain a weak pawn and the
lines of attack will open up now so the
captures knight captures putting
pressure on this bishop here on d2 we
have rook to c2 also the rook is
attacked so you could move it all the
way back to c1 but rook the c2 seems uh
uh provide a little bit more protection
to not only the bishop but also to the
e-2 pawn but bishop to f5 now attacking
or rather x-raying the the rook here on
c2 queen to c1 and now knight back to d6
attacking the rook and also the pawn on
e2 so as you see you will not be able to
keep the spawn so rook to c5 we have
rook captures on e2 now
and bishop to e3 so is the rook trapped
on e2 uh it would be if white could
attack it in any way but there's no good
way to attack this rook so here just
bishop to e4 and now uh you you don't
have a move if you attack it with the
queen we just capture on b2 the b2 pawn
is undefended so here rook to d1 instead
uh putting the rook on the open d file
uh queen to f6 now threatening to win
material with bishop captures on f3 so
knights to d4 only move for envelope uh
to keep fighting here bishop captures
and g2 king captures and the knight
captures on d4 we have bishop captures
attacking the queen and queen to g6 now
with some with some tricky ideas of
maybe queen to e4 check or you can go to
at the g4 and then bring the knight into
the game maybe knight to f5 knight h for
check knight to f3 so a lot of attacking
possibilities for wesley here uh and uh
you kind of should play queen to f4
prevent the queen from infiltrating and
that that should be good for white but
here uh mvl said all right i'm down upon
i better grab a pawn and then hope hope
for the best so he captures on c7 uh and
now we have knight to f5 but uh instead
of knight to f5 you could also go rook
eight to e8 just doubling up on the e
file also uh looks uh it looks like it
can be played and then you're gonna
bring the knight into the game and so on
but okay uh it's a rapid game knight two
f5 was played rook to c8 with check
forcing a rook trade captures captures
with czech king the h7 and queen
captures and b7 so by uh
envel was down upon now all of a sudden
nbl is up upon but wesley will get his
chance to attack so now queen g4 now we
are okay we're defending our own rook
but we are going for knight h for check
and then the knight can come to f3 even
though the queen is now guarding the f3
square but the king will have to move so
h3 attacking the queen and this is one
of the nicest positions uh in the game
that i really thought you guys will
enjoy
uh here after h3 pretty much everyone
everyone would go for queen captures on
g3 this is such an automatic move and
you would all obviously be very happy
that you can play it the f pawn is
pinned you cannot capture the problem is
after king to f1 your queen is attacked
and also your rook is hanging here so
how do you
how do you play this well you would have
to go into this forced uh force line
it's the only one that doesn't lose rook
to e7 you attack the white queen now we
play f captures on g3 rook captures on
b7 and we move the bishop so this is the
the resulting end game and now you can
either capture on b2 or you can put
pressure with rook to b3 all in all uh
for the moment it's equal material but
black will be a little a little bit
better due to uh more activity or just
by grabbing a pawn uh so this is uh this
is possible but uh uh wesley wants
wesley wants more he plays queen to g6
he wants to keep everything on the board
uh and now king to f1 attacking the rook
rook back to e4 now putting pressure on
the bishop here and queen to d5
defending the bishop uh you can't really
capture the rook of course if you
capture the rook then it's game over
queen captures rook knight captures on
g3 with a check it's not only fork by
the night but also after the knight is
captured the queen will capture the
queen and now black is completely
winning so queen to d5 and now we have
rook to e6
uh
here you could also go for rook captures
on d4 it seems like maybe it's time to
just trade everything down but this game
uh was never really about that here both
players are just playing for the win the
classical portion of the tournament is
over this is now rapid so
neither
maxine nor wesley want to draw here
let's say queen to c2 let's say a4 now
the white queen is defending everything
and you will have a hard time drawing
this white is up upon white will be
pushing end as they say in a queen and
opponent game upon up means means
winning basically so here after queen to
d5 we have rooked the e6 instead and now
comes uh bishop the c5 by by mvl and uh
this is uh very very tricky so just uh
just to show you how beautiful this line
is bishop to c3 is the move that needs
to be played but it's a very
uh very hard to figure out why but i
will show you the reason why bishop the
c3 is so strong uh is
uh well let's let's first show you what
happens after bishop the c5 now the
problem is uh queen to h5 going after
the h3 pawn and here wesley is saying
you do not have g4 if you have g4 uh
then obviously you can play it but the
problem is after g4 queen captures an h3
with check queen to g2 now uh black has
queen to b3 which would not be possible
if the bishop was in c3 because here
white would be winning uh but black has
this queen to b3 move now black is
attacking the rook on d1 and you don't
have a good way of of uh dealing with
this you have to simply defend with
queen to d5 now we just repeat queen to
h3 chair queen to g2 and queen to b3 so
and that's why uh the the the bishop was
much needed on c3 so this is exactly the
reason why after this queen to h5 move
uh maxime does not play g4 he sees that
this will be a fourth draw he plays h4
instead uh well simply doesn't allow the
capture on h3 uh but now comes queen to
g4 now interestingly uh here wesley is
completely winning but the both of them
i think uh are
you know just blitzing out moves uh
they are very low on time just queen to
e2 check wins on the spot king g2 rook
e5 and you cannot defend uh the either
the bishop falls or the rook falls so
yeah
you cannot keep can't keep an eye on
everything uh but okay after h4 uh queen
the g4 was played instead and now comes
well now you are threatening uh
preparing rook to f6 basically then you
want to capture on g3 so uh both of them
are basically just looking at uh
their own threats uh b4 a captures a
captures just creating a pass b pawn you
can never go wrong with that rook to f6
now threatening uh knight captures on g3
and king the e1 unpinning and here maxim
will now start uh running with his king
uh rook to e6 chuck king to d2 we have
queen to g6 now uh well if the king
continues running away across this
diagonal then we will have some very
nasty discoveries so rook to e1 hoping
to get a rook trading then you can maybe
start pushing your past b pawn now comes
uh
rook to a6 just uh trying to get the
rook behind uh behind the king maybe
rook to a3 if the queen moves
from this diagonal maybe even rook to a
to check will be possible
now rook to e5 attacking the knight here
and knight the d6 so uh wesley is
keeping uh everything nicely defended
but here comes h5 attacking the queen
queen to f6 and the knockout pawn to f4
and here uh wesley is basically without
without a good move but uh uh both of
them are very very low on time uh that
doesn't really matter so knights to if i
was played here hoping for rook captures
on f5 then you can play queen to b to
check and then the white king will be in
trouble so g4 by mbl knights the h4 and
now comes queen to e4 with check we have
g6 now blocking this uh and now b5
attacking the rook so now okay you do
have one check but not then uh bishop
controls a3 you will not be able to go
back and deliver a check on the third
rank so rook to a5 instead and now pawn
to b6 nvl spawn is already on b6 ready
to ready to become a queen uh and here
we have queen to d8 with check uh here
rook captures on c5 and grabbing the
b-pawn uh is is pretty good but after
rook to c6 there's just so much pressure
on that g6 square and you will probably
not be able to
find some sort of a perpetual check
checking
a mechanism so white will white will be
winning this so instead we have queen to
d8 with check by wesley king the c3 and
now comes queen to d1 and now okay even
though white is better it's very very
unpleasant having the rook and king rook
and queen behind your king and uh well
uh with a little time on the clock
you will almost always lose this so here
we have queen to c2 uh adding a defender
here queen to a1 with check king to b4
and now comes knight back to f3 uh here
wesley misses rook to a2 this describes
the queen because if the queen moves
rook to b to check and the white king um
the white king
will soon be dead uh so here you would
have to trade queens but still it's not
all that clear king to b5 we're gonna
put a king on c6 start pushing that pawn
for example if queen here preventing
this we can even play rook to e7 push
the pawn and it's still black who's
better but it would be incredibly
interesting
but okay knight to f3 by wesley and then
now comes queen to b3
uh here h captures on g6 is winning just
moving the rook as the knight is
threatening to capture it is winning uh
but interestingly maxine plays queen to
b3 and it's the only move that actually
loses the game from this position uh so
now wesley just captures the rook the
knight captures on e5 f captures on e5
and queen to e1 with check now the rook
is being guarded by the queen
and here queen to c4 and now wesley is
completely winning uh but he has to play
the correct move and now feel free to
pause the video as this is incredibly
difficult to
calculate uh so feel free to pause the
video and figure it out while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliant maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
not queen to e2 with chuck it is queen
to c1 with check and we will show why
this is so uh because if king the b4
then queen captures and c5 is checkmate
and if you move the king well then you
just lose the bishop so queen to c1 is
the correct way to go obviously queen to
c3 loses the whatever we can i either
capture the bishop here uh or or the
queen uh both both is winning not just
queen captures on c3 and that's it so
what you would have to do after queen to
c1 check is move the king somewhere else
but now the bishop is hanging and we can
even throw in a few more checks that's a
king before queen f2 chicken now once
the king moves wherever uh we pick up
the bishop and that's it if b7 yes it's
a pawn very close to promotion but we
can just play a couple of checks akin to
d2 now we pick up the queen we got the
queening square and that's it
so uh after king the c4 uh queen to c1
completely winning for wesley but wesley
played queen to e2 with check and it
looks also very nice uh if um if uh uh
mvl makes a silly move uh but he makes
the strongest move he plays king to d5
and now uh still with the g captures on
h5 it's uh it's it's a draw but after
queen captures on g4 now it's a problem
king to d6 by maxine and now we have
well now with queen to f5 it's still a
fight but after queen the c8 uh this is
what wesley played and he was in this
position after he played it that he
immediately resigned the game as he
completely missed that the queen was
attacking f7 so here he resigned and
that's basically the story of this game
uh if you allow queen captures on f7
then everything completely falls apart
we can start uh giving checks and
clearing all the pawns queen captures
here king of faith queen captures with
check king g8 queen g6 czech let's say
king of f8 and now it seems like black
might still have something but after a
move like a bishop to b4 there is no
move you can make your rook is hanging
and also if you give one little check to
the to the white king we can just open
up a discovery from the bishop and
that's it you have to play something to
block the check and now queen f7 will be
checkmate uh so that's the reason why
after queen the c8 wesley resigned and
what uh what a brilliant brilliant
victory for maxine bashar gruff uh you
can see uh wesley was uh winning for uh
for a large uh part of the game then
maxine was winning then wesley was again
winning then maxine was winning so it's
really a really a crazy crazy game and
this is the games that we um
enjoy the most uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys hope you guys
enjoyed it and once again
congratulations to everyone who spotted
that uh queen to eat uh queen to c1 is
the only winning move here uh but uh
it's uh uh it's always hard to imagine
how how a player of wesley's caliber
would miss this is it's it's basically
winning on the spot uh but uh chess is
is just brutal chess is ruthless and
chess always finds that next victim that
that will be asking um uh him or herself
you know how did i play such a
uh such a silly silly move uh so yeah
that's uh that's the game once again
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank nagarjuna
david kimura uh john guilfoyle dominic
novieli and adam rosenberg for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon uh continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day